dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana affair imagine
if we had an accurate algorithm to
simulate how different sound effects
would propagate in a virtual world we
would find computer games exhibiting
gunfire in open areas or a pianist
inside a castle courtyard to be way more
immersive and we've been waiting for
efficient techniques for this for quite
a while now this is a research field
where convolutions enjoy quite a bit of
attention due to the fact that they are
a reliable and efficient way to
approximate how a given signal would
sound in a room with given geometry and
material properties however the key word
is approximate this however is one of
those past sampling techniques that
gives us the real deal so quite excited
for that so what about this path
sampling thing this means an actual
simulation of sound waves
we have a vast literature and decades of
experience in simulating how rays of
light bounce and reflect around in a
scene and leaning on this knowledge we
can create beautiful photorealistic
images the first idea is to adapt the
mathematical framework of light
simulations to be able to do the very
same with sound waves path tracing is a
technique where we build light paths
from the camera bounce them around in a
scene and hope that we hit a light
source with these rays if this happens
then we compute the amount of energy
that is transferred from the light
source to the camera note that energy is
a more popular and journalistic term
here what researchers actually measure
here is a quantity called radiance the
main contribution of this work is
adapting by directional path tracing to
sound this is a technique originally
designed for light simulations that
builds light paths from both the light
source and the camera at the same time
and it is significantly more efficient
than the classical path tracer on
difficult indoor scenes and of course
the main issue with these methods is
that they have to simulate a large
number of rays to obtain a satisfactory
result and many of these rays don't
contribute anything to the final result
only a small subset of them are
responsible for most of the image we see
we hear it is a bit like the Pareto
principle or the 80/20 rule on steroids
[Music]
please
this is ice cream for my ears love it
this work also introduces a metric to
not only be able to compare similar
sound synthesis techniques in the future
but the proposed technique is built
around minimizing this metric which
leads us to an idea on which rays carry
important information and which ones we
are better off discarding I also like
this mini-map on the upper left that
actually shows what we hear in this
footage exactly where the sound sources
are and how they change their positions
looking forward to seeing and listening
to similar presentations in future
papers in this area typical member for
the execution time of the algorithm is
between 15 to 20 milliseconds per frame
on a consumer-grade processor that is
about 50 to 65 frames per second the
position of the sound sources makes a
great deal of difference for the
classical path tracer the bi-directional
path tracer however is not only more
effective but offers significantly more
consistent results as well
this new method is especially useful in
these cases there are way more details
explained in the paper for instance it
also supports path caching and also
borrows the all-powerful multiple
importance sampling from photorealistic
rendering research have a look thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time
[Music]